Hallo, schönen guten Tag. Mein Name ist Bayrak. Ich bin auf die Sistation als Astronautin tätig und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegeschrieb befürchten. Bitte unterbrechen Sie mich, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen oder wenn Sie Fragen haben.
Alles klar.
Bevor Sie mir Ihre Beschwerden erzählen, ich würde gerne ein paar allgemeine Fragen stellen. Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Helmut Schmidt.
Helmut Schmidt.
Herr Schmidt, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 62 Jahre alt.
62.
Mhm. Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 12. März 1962.
12. März 1962.
60.
Mhm. Und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,75 m groß.
5,75 m. Wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich bin ungefähr 90 kg schwer.
90 kg schwer. Okay, Herr Schmidt, was fühlt Sie uns? Wie kann ich Ihnen halten?
Ja, also ich bin heute Morgen beim Frühstück habe ich Probleme gehabt, den Kaffee, die Kaffee-Tasse zu greifen.
Und dann habe ich ein Taubweißgefühl gehabt.
Und dann ist mir das Glas aus der Hand gefallen.
Und ich hatte plötzlich ein Taubweißgefühl im rechten Bein.
Hm, okay.
Und rechnen, nein.
Nur in die beide Hände oder dieser Taubweißgefühl?
Rechten Bein und welche Hand er betroffen?
Und rechte Hand.
Rechte Hand.
Okay.
Seit heute Morgen haben Sie früher eingebetscht?
Das war heute Morgen, ja, so gegen 9 Uhr morgens war das.
Das ist jetzt schon ein bisschen besser geworden, aber konnte ich das nicht greifen.
Ich konnte nicht besonders gehen.
Und jetzt ist es schon ein bisschen besser.
Ein bisschen besser.
Haben Sie früher einige Beschwerden gehabt?
Nein, noch nie.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Sprachen oder Sehen?
Sehen habe ich keine Probleme, aber ich hatte ein bisschen Probleme zu antworten.
Das ist schon wieder weg.
Manchmal kann ich mich nur ein bisschen anstottern, aber sonst ist das wieder weg.
Sie haben ein Taubweißgefühl.
Außerdem haben Sie Kraftlosigkeit, können Sie normal bewegen Sie sich?
Ja, ich kann mich normal bewegen, aber das war heute Morgen,
hat mir das Angst gemacht.
Ja, okay.
Und haben Sie jetzt, ja, haben Sie Fieber?
Ich habe kein Fieber, nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang oder beim Wasserlastung?
Nein, gar nicht.
Okay.
Ich habe keine Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang oder beim Wasserlastung.
Nein, gar nicht.
Okay.
Und diese Taubweißgefühl, wie lange dauert, Sie sagten jetzt, es ist besser?
Ja, das hat ungefähr so eine Stunde gedauert, 45 Minuten, eine Stunde ungefähr.
Eine Stunde gedauert.
Okay.
Und jetzt,
haben Sie andere Sanzivitätsstörungen oder in den anderen Körperteilen?
Nein, in den anderen Körperteilen, nicht nur in der rechten Hand ein bisschen.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Nacken?
Für die habe Kante Nackenprobleme?
Eigentlich nicht.
Okay.
Ja.
Und jetzt würde ich gerne ein paar allgemeine Fragen stellen zu Ihrem allgemeinen Zustand.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Eigentlich schon, ja.
Mhm.
Und gut.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit ab oder zu genommen?
Nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie Schwitzen?
Ich weiß nicht, ich weiß ausbüchern.
Nein.
Mhm.
Okay.
Und haben Sie, ist Ihnen aufgefallen Ihre Herz mehr, oder Herz als normale Mehrschlag, oder Herz?
Mein Herz schneller schlägt.
Hah, schneller schlägt, ja.
Ja, ist mir nicht aufgefallen, nein.
Mhm.
Okay.
Und jetzt suchen wir Ihre Vorerkrankungen.
Haben Sie eine manche Vorerkrankungen von den, ich wüsste, zum Beispiel,
Bluthochdruck oder Suckerkrankheit oder hohe Blutfettwerte?
Ich habe einen Bluthochdruck, der seit fünf Jahren behandelt wird.
Seit fünf Jahren.
Mhm.
Ähm, messen Sie Ihre Blutdruck regermäßig?
Eigentlich nicht, lange nicht mehr.
lange nicht mehr.
Mhm.
Was nehmen Sie dagegen, nein?
Ramipril.
Ramipril. Kennen Sie die Dosierung?
Ja, fünf Milligramm.
fünf Milligramm. Einmal morgens oder zweimal?
Einmal morgens.
Okay.
Sie sagten, Sie messen nicht mehr lange.
Nein, weil ich keine Beschwerden habe eigentlich.
Hm, okay.
Und kontrollieren Sie, wann war die letzte Kontrolle für die
Blutdruck, wann war Ihre letzte Arztbesucht?
Boah, das ist schon jetzt bestimmt halbes Jahr her.
Halbes Jahr.
Okay.
Haben Sie eine andere Krankheit, außer dann Bluthochdruck?
Nein, mein Hausarzt hatte mir mal alles drin.
Ähm, Medikament aufgeschrieben, aber ehrlich gesagt,
nehme ich die da nicht ein.
Mhm.
Nehmen Sie nicht.
Okay.
Also dann haben Sie eine andere Krankheit?
Nein, glaube ich.
Gott sei Dank nicht.
Okay, Herr Schmidt.
Und außer dann Ramikril nehmen Sie eine andere Medikamente,
die Sie dabei haben.
Ich nehme wegen meiner Migräne, nämlich oft Ibuprofen ein.
Mhm.
Aber nur, wenn Sie Schmerzen haben.
Ja, genau.
Ich habe ab und zu Migräne und das dann nämlich dann Ibuprofen ein.
Ja, ähm, haben Sie Kopfschmerzen?
Aktuell nicht.
Also ich habe wegen meiner Migräne ab und zu Kopfschmerzen,
aber aktuell habe ich keine Kopfschmerzen, nein.
Mhm, okay.
Ja.
Okay, und Ibuprofen kennen Sie die Dosierung?
Ich nehme die 600 ein.
600?
Okay.
Ähm, außer dann Ibuprofen und Ramikril nehmen Sie eine andere Medikamente?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Nein.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Allergie gegen bestimmte Medikamente oder nachungsschmitteil?
Soweit, ich weiß nicht.
Mhm.
Aber Unverträglichkeit?
Ich habe eine Penicillin-Unverträglichkeit in meiner Kindheit gehabt,
aber ich habe schon lange keine Penicillin mehr genommen, ich weiß es nicht.
Ja, okay.
Äh, leben alle Alten noch?
Meine Eltern sind beide verstorben.
Tut mir leid, darf ich fragen, woran sind sie gestorben?
Also meine Vater ist in einem Herz, in Fahrt verstorben,
meine Mutter ist in einem Schlag am Fahrt verstorben.
Und im Märch am Alter?
Also beide waren schon über 80.
Über 80.
Okay.
Ja.
Ähm, jetzt guckern wir Ihre Sozialgäste.
Was sind Sie vor mir rufen?
Ich bin Rennner.
Rennner.
Ich war Lehrer.
Mhm.
Gut.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich habe eine Ehepfrau.
Ehepfrau.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein.
Mhm.
Okay.
Ähm, haben Sie Stress,
im Soz der Leben?
Eigentlich gar nicht, mir geht es eigentlich sehr gut.
Mhm.
Okay.
Haben Sie finanzielle Sorgen oder andere?
Überhaupt nicht, nein.
Überhaupt nicht.
Nein.
Okay, Herr Schimmitz.
Ich bin fertig mit meiner Frage.
Ich möchte eine kurze Zusammenfassung machen.
Sie haben seit heute Morgen ein Taubheitsgefüll
in rechter Handel oder rechter Beine.
Aber außerdem in den anderen Körperteile
haben Sie nicht diese Sachen.
Wenn Sie Kaffee trinken,
dann bemerkten Sie diese Taubheitsgefüll,
danach die, äh, äh,
danach es hat besser geworden.
Und Sie haben erstes Mal
eine solche Sache gehabt.
Und Sie haben keine Probleme
beim Bewegung oder beim Sehen.
Aber Sie haben...
Beim Gehen habe ich schon Schwierigkeiten,
ein bisschen.
Ein bisschen beim Gehen habe ich schon Schwierigkeiten.
Ich habe dir gesagt, dass ich auch am Bein so Taubalsgefühle habe.
Ja, aber Sie haben keine Kraftlosigkeit.
Doch habe ich gehabt, habe ich gehabt, 45 Minuten lang, eine Stunde lang ungefähr.
Okay.
Sie haben ein bisschen Probleme, wenn Sie antworten.
Und Sie haben kein Fieber.
Sie haben keine Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang oder beim Wasserlassen.
Diese Bäche werden ungefähr eine Stunde gedauert.
Danach wird es besser sein.
Sie haben keine nacken Probleme oder Kopfschmerzen.
Und Sie haben seit fünf Jahren Bluthochdruck.
Aber Sie haben lange nicht mehr gemessen.
Und nehmen Sie dagegen Ramipril.
Außerdem haben Sie hohe Blut, kolesterol, Ringwerte.
Aber Sie nehmen keine Medikamente ein.
Und Sie haben außerdem Migräne.
Und Sie haben Unverzweglichkeit gegen Penzin.
Aber das ist schon lange.
Und Ihre Mutter und Vater, die beide gestorben über 16 Jahren.
Ihr Vater hatte Herzinfarkt.
Und Ihre Mutter hatte Schulackanfall.
Ja, Herr Schimit, haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, ich möchte wissen, ob das was Gefährliches sein könnte.
Und sehr beruhigend.
Ja, gute Frage, Herr Schimit.
Wir haben nur eine Anamnesegespräch durchgeführt.
Erstmal muss ich in den Körper untersofern.
Danach werde ich für Labors Blut abnehmen.
Sobald alle Ergebnisse bekommen, werde ich wieder bei Ihnen sein.
Und wir werden Ihre Situation besprechen.
Jetzt denken Sie nicht am schlimmsten Fall.
Einige unterschiedliche Krankheiten spricht für diese Situation.
Erst mal, wir müssen diese, die ich erwähnte Verfahren führen.
Dann muss ich also hier bleiben.
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Danke schön.
Haben Sie Kollegen oder Kollegen noch andere Fragen?
Ja, ich habe ein paar Fragen.
Bitte schön, zwei Fragen, Maximum.
Maximum, haben Sie bewusster Verloren bemerkt?
Nein.
Haben Sie bei Ihnen schwindel oder in der letzten Zeit?
Auch nicht.
Haben Sie bemerkt, in Ihrem Gesicht eine Asymmetrie zu sein?
Haben Sie nicht verstanden?
Haben Sie bemerkt, in Ihrem Gesicht eine Asymmetrie bemerkt?
Nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt, hat meine Frau auch nicht gesagt.
Brauchen Sie?
Ich habe früher geraucht.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ein Moment kurz, bitte ganz kurz.
Weiter.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Sehr selten.
Ich wurde noch nie bisher operiert.
Ich war auch nicht im Ausland gewesen.
Im Status?
Im Status sagte mein Haushaltswähre komplett.
Hatten Sie gelegentliche Haustopern aufgepasst?
Nein, hatte ich aber schon antwortet.
Ja, während.
Okay, eine zweite Frage ist, bitte, Moment.
Hatten Sie nur bei Problemen, nur bei Gesprächen oder haben Sie Probleme auch bei Verstehen?
Hab ich keine Probleme gehabt.
Das Problem war eher in der Hand und den Fuß.
Die Sprache war nicht so beeinträchtigt.
Das war nur ein bisschen verspättes Antworten, würde ich sagen.
Aber das ist schon wieder fast weg.
Nur noch ein wenig totter.
Verstanden, danke.
Ich habe eine Frage gestellt.
Ich werde noch eine Frage stellen.
Haben Sie gesagt, Sie Migran hat?
Ja, seit wann haben Sie die Migrene?
Und welche, wenn Sie eine schlechte Migran-Attacke haben,
welche Symptome haben Sie?
Ich habe die Migrate schon sehr lange, also über 20 Jahre schon.
Ich stimme meistens über Propfene dafür.
Das hilft mir gut.
Ich habe nur einenseits Kopfschmerzen.
Nur Kopfschmerzen oder andere Symptome gibt es?
Nein, ich habe keine anderen Symptome.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Gerne.
Traf diese Beschwerden erst mal auf?
Ja, wo beantwortet, ja.
Sie hatten früher eine Penicillin-Allergie.
Wie hat dies damals äußerst sich?
Da war ich ein Kind, ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Da hatte meine Mutter damals gesagt, ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Aber ich stimme momentan keine Penicillin ein.
Verstehe.
Okay.
Danke, wir haben es schon angefangen.
Bitte schön.
Okay.
Ich fange an.
Hallo, sehr geehrter Herr Oberarzt.
Heute habe ich einen neuen Patient aufgenommen.
Ich würde gerne Ihnen von meinem Patienten erzählen.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit? Darf ich?
Ja, noch ein bisschen.
Danke schön.
Herr Schimit ist 62 Jahre alt.
1,75 cm und 90 kg.
Er stellte sich heute mit, seit heute Morgen,
seit heute Morgen angefangen,
Parästhesie in Rehtanbein und im rechten Handel.
Das ist eine sehr große Parästhesie.
Es ist eine sehr große Parästhesie.
Das berichtete, dass er über die Sprache
von der Erkrankung hatte.
Er hatte noch die Beschwerden eine Stunde gedauert.
Er klagte über die Kraftlosigkeit.
Die Fragen nach Perrexie, Sefalgi, Sinkope wurden verneint.
Die Vegetativanamnese war unauffällig.
Die Fragen nach Gewichtverlust, Hyperhydrosis, Pachycardia und die Somni
wurden verneint.
An Vorerkrankungen leide er an arterieller Hepatone seit 5 Jahren,
die mit Rhamipyrel behandelt wurde, 5 mg,
an meinem Morgen.
Er berichtete, er habe seit langer Zeit
ihre Blutdruck nicht gemessen, ungefähr halbis Jahr.
Er leide an Hypercholesterinwerte,
aber dagegen nehme er keine Medikamente ein.
Außerdem habe er Migräne, er nehme über 1,6 mg bei Bedarf ein.
Die Allergien seien bei ihm nicht bekannt,
als habe Unverträglichkeit gegen Penicillin,
aber es war im Kindalter, jetzt sehe ich nicht die Haare.
Die Familien am Nase Al-Gab, Myokat Infarkt,
beim Vater und Apoplex bei der Mutter,
und die Mutter und Vater seien über 60 Jahren gestorben.
Er war 80 Jahre gestorben,
und er war Erlehrer von Beruf.
Er wurde verheiratet,
er hatte keine Kinder,
und hatte keinen Stress,
weil Soziallebnemite ja.
Können Sie kurz die Symptome zusammenfassen?
Nur die Symptome.
Er hatte Parasitische,
rechte Beine und rechte Handel,
die beschwerden nur 1 Stunde gedauert seien,
und er leide an Kraftlosigkeit,
und die Symptome,
die er enthalten,
er hat eine Beziehung,
und er hat eine Beziehung,
er leide an Kraftlosigkeit,
und die Beschwerden seien erstes mal betroffen.
Eingetroffen?
Eingetroffen, ja.
Ist das jetzt wieder weg, oder ist es doch da?
Nein, wieder weg.
Also keine Probleme mehr.
Oder hatte noch Beschwerden?
Nein, er sagte nur 1 Stunde gedauert,
und jetzt habe er keine Beschwerden mehr.
Also hat keine Taubweizgefühle mehr,
den Fuß, in den Händen, gar nichts?
Ich habe nicht wieder gefragt, aber er sagte das.
Okay, was haben Sie für eine Verdachtdiagnose
bei den Patienten?
Die Klinikian,
meine Verdachtdiagnose ist,
eine Migräne-Attacke.
Die für als differential Diagnose kommen in
vielleicht unkontrollierte
Hypertonie-Attacken,
oder eine Apoplex.
Noch mal?
Oder eine vorübergehende,
diese Beschwerden wie ein Apoplex,
aber ja, ist chemische Attacke aber vorübergehende.
Also meine transistorische, chemische Attacke?
Genau.
Welches von den Diagnosen passt dann eher?
Was glauben Sie?
Kann eine Migräne Paubweizgefühle im Fuß machen,
dass er nicht gehen kann?
Diese Tär ist am besten, passt diese.
Würde ich auch erst mal sagen,
oder er hat sogar vielleicht ein Gefäßverschluss gehabt,
oder hat immer noch ein Gefäßverschluss,
aber die Symptome sind besser geworden.
Das kann auch sein.
Ja, aber ich habe eine Frage.
Diese Gefäßverschlussattacke im Gehen.
Ja, es muss, wenn Sie die Pferdziagnose haben
und wenn der Patient jetzt es ihm besser geht,
dann müssten Sie auf jeden Fall dran denken,
ob es eine transistorische chemische Attacke sein könnte,
oder ob es tatsächlich eine Stenose irgendwo gibt.
Richtig?
Ja, genau.
Wo könnten die Stenosen denn sein?
Stenosen, also Sie meinen im welchem Gefäß, oder?
Wenn Sie den Verdacht haben,
der hat die Beschwerden rechts.
Ja, Beschwerden rechts, dann schreibt Karotis.
Aber...
Karotis, richtig?
Gleichstrucks links.
Rechts.
Weil das ist untergehört.
Okay.
Welche Diagnostik machen Sie bei den Patienten?
Welche Diagnostik?
Für die Tia ein schnell CT kann man durchführen.
Und natürlich erstmal, ich muss körperlicher untersuchen,
gibt es andere Zauberpastgefühl oder Kraftlosigkeit,
die in den anderen Körperteilen gibt oder nicht.
Sprachkanten und Reflexen, Popel und so.
Und ich muss Blutdruck messen.
Und ja, danach, nach dieser Körperleuteutung...
Also kann es auch eine hypotensive Krise sein?
Ja, eine hypotensive Krise, nicht so direkt wie diese,
aber er hat schon lange ihre Blutdruck nicht gemessen.
Also auch eine Differenzialdiagnose?
Ja, also Differenzialdiagnose, ja, nicht verdacht.
Und ich werde Blut abnehmen,
weil er nehme keine Kollektage.
Er habe hohe Kollesternmärkte und er nehme keine dagegen Medikamente ein.
Ich würde gerne Blut abnehmen und diese Kollesternmärkte
und Infektionsparameter und ja.
Und ich habe mein EKG?
Ja, ein EKG und CT auch mit.
Und das EKG ist auch richtig, warum?
Warum?
Weil diese Beschwerden ist vorübergehende.
Und wenn eine hohe Kollesternmärkte gibt,
dann kann die Herzkranzgefäße verschließen.
Und das kann eine Arrythmi führen.
Und dann kann was passieren?
Ich warte mit dieser Situation.
Wenn er eine Arrythmi hat,
welche Konsequenz hat das?
Was kann dann passieren?
Das kann Arrythmi passieren.
Kann eine Arrythmi solche Symptome verursachen?
Solche Symptome.
Arrythmi kann Weiziger.
Kann eine Arrythmi,
ein Haubwebsgefühl, Kraftverlust,
lords Beinrechte,
ansmachen?
Ja, mit Embolik am machen.
Genau, richtig, sehr gut, deswegen
müssten Sie auf jeden Fall eine EKG nachschauen.
Wie geht es nicht primär, um zu gucken,
ob ein Herzinfarkt hat,
sondern zu gucken ob ein Rhythmusstörung besteht.
Die ihr gar nicht bemerkt, richtig?
man seit einem Jahr, aber bemerkt es aber nicht. Er nimmt ja auch kein ASS ein oder so was oder
kein Lutzverdenner, richtig? Genau. Deswegen ist sein EKG sehr, sehr wichtig hier. Was sollte man
noch machen, wenn man den Patienten aufnimmt stationär, welche Untersuchung? Sie haben gesagt,
CT, EKG, was kann man noch machen? Kann man auch eine Ambulanz machen, wenn man gut ist?
Wenn gibt es keine Probleme im CT oder EKG, dann... Macht man meist stationär, man kann einen
Ultraschall der Karottes machen. Okay. Richtig? Ja. Okay, ich glaube, das ist so weit okay.
Welche Diagnose, bei welcher Diagnose bleiben wir? Jetzt, wir sind im TR. TR oder leichter
ischämische Schlaganfall. Okay? Genau. Würde ich als Arbeitsdiagnose nehmen? Das passt am
ersten. Ein Migräneanfall, schwierig. Also, Migräneanfall könnte natürlich auch sein,
aber er hat normalerweise seit 20 Jahren ganz andere Symptomatik. Er hat Kopfschmerzen,
er hat keine Aura, keine neurologischen Ausfälle. Richtig? Genau. Und er nimmt...
Von da an ist es mir vom schlimmsten ausgehen und sagen, es muss erst mal einen Schlaganfall
ausgeschlossen werden. Also ein Apoplex.
Der Patient, bei der Anemnese hat gesagt, gewichtstörungen. Nein. Nein.
Da ist noch eine Frage. Ja. Wir haben gesagt, als Verdacht Diagnose ischämische Insel zuerst,
aber es ist möglich, hemorologische, kleine hemorologische Insel auch. Sie haben
arterielle Hypertone und sie nicht regelmäßig gemessen. Richtig. Viellei hemorologische
Insel auch. Kann sein. Ja. Ja, Verdacht Diagnose oder die Veranstalung Diagnose.
Kann auch sein. Das wissen wir meistens erst, wenn wir einen CT gemacht haben oder
besser MRT gemacht haben. Aber kann ich... Transstitial ischämische Attacke.
Oder leichter ischämischer Schlaganfall, kann man auch sagen. Also warum,
warum es kann auch ein Tier sein, aber er hat ja noch ein wenig Symptome gehabt eigentlich.
Frau Dilleruba, ich hatte das am Anfang gesagt. Er hat noch leichtes Taubheitsgefühl.
Ganz am Anfang habe ich gesagt, noch leichtes Taubheitsgefühl. Er hat noch leichte Beschwerden.
Die sind rückläufig, aber die sind noch da. Und daher kann man sagen, dass es ein ischämischer Schlaganfall ist.
Man kann auch sagen Tier, aber bei Tier sind die Symptome ganz rückläufig normalerweise.
Also, der hat gar nichts mehr. Hemoragie kann auch sein als Diagnose.
Ich würde es aber eher bei einem leichtes ischämischen Schlaganfall belassen.
Vielleicht hat er einen Emulus durch Karottischdinosus bei Hypercholesteroid.
Er hat dann wieder rübergegangen oder er hat Beauflimmern doch tatsächlich wissen, wie ich.
Darf ich fragen? Wie kann man über Gleichgewichtigkeit, Probleme und Apraxie fragen?
Habt ihr Gleichgewichtsstörungen gehabt?
Die Hausarbeit machen oder können sie?
Das war ja nur eine Stunde. Er hat die Beschwerden nur eine Stunde gehabt.
Kurzzeitige neurologische Ausfälle.
Noch eine Frage. Wir haben einen Schlaganfall ischämischer oder hemoragischer.
Sollen wir Fragen über Gleichgewichtigkeit oder Erbrechen? Wir haben nicht gefragt.
Okay, ja, das ist eine wichtige Frage. Klar. Man hat ja meistens bei, so will ich das weiß,
bei Hemoragie oft auch Übelkeit erbrechen, wenn man eine Blutung hat.
Bei schweren Blutungen habe ich schon oft erlebt, dass die Patienten ja bluten und dann nicht
Bluten erbrechen.
Aber unsere Kollegen haben noch etwas Ungewöhnliches gemacht.
Natürlich, das ist auch ein Problem.
Aber die Patienten haben nicht gesagt, aber beide Köpferlöcher haben auch Fragen.
Das ist ein Problem.